non ans catherine
bonjour catherine bonjour laurent
boucher à linda qu'est ce que c'est
c'est de la poule 4 i dans deux mois
catherine il s'appelle catherine colle
et a fini 4 4 voilà alors vous sortez
deux cd alors je vous ai dit white ra à
côté parce que vous êtes tous un peu
dans le même dans le même mode 1 je vais
expliquer pourquoi après donc vous
sortez de deux cd il ya un qui s'appelle
les créatures l'autre qui s'appelle
l'homme à trois mains celui qu'on va
entendre après c'est ça
c'est bien pour la mission est ce qu'on
le 11 décembre c'est vachement bien
alors catherine vous êtes né dans le
bocage vendéen c'est vrai un petit
village s'appelle chantonnay on reçoit
des gens des petits villages aujourd'hui
philippe ménard de barsac philippe
katerine de chanteuse c'est la vie
d'avant ces gens là c'est même plus guy
lux et là c'est jean-noël alors vous
êtes d'une famille catholique j'ai eu
une enfance mystique un philippe bozon
que catholiques en tout quarante ans on
voulait être prêtre
oui d'être fasciné par les icônes on dit
juste oui oui parce qu'on est pressé et
oui
ceci explique peut être le style un peu
naïf un peut nier un peu les rythmes un
peu bébête de vos chansons
oui voilà il dit oui alors vous avez une
grande propension philippa bêtifier à
ânonner à faire un peu simplet oui et ce
que j'ai mis à côté d'eux parce qu'il ya
une mode en ce moment de la crétine six
fois une mauvaise mode la crétinerie
j'étais vierge c'est une vraie et nous
sommes des chrétiens houellebecq il ya
philippe katerine y avoue c'est un peu à
la mode de jouer les guinéens peut lire
c'est à la mode
bah si en plus on joue pas aux crétins
je m'attendais à l'écrêtage son talent
mais tu préférais ah oui voila voila
c'est pas des combats des états des gens
qui ne seraient pas crétin qui jouerait
être crétin vous avez repéré comme c'est
la mode des crétins de telles batailles
mieux mais ce serait dit on verra vie
alors vous dites l'idée même de
l'intelligence au service de la chanson
me fait fuir
ouais ouais j'aime ta wii cette idée là
je passe tellement d'exemples oui mais
bon je fais avec les moyens du bord sûr
je suis pas spécialement intelligent
intelligent je fais faute de mieux qua
non mais attendez si vous invitez c'est
qu'on aime bien votre me dise pas
maintenant on vous dit que c'est pas la
peine de faire d'être intelligent beau
faire de bonnes chansons c'est ça je
crois
bon c'est pas incompatible non plus mais
c'est pas nécessaire chers amis chers
ennemis